would it be cool if iris was just really
good so I really didn't like the last
two and I want this one to WoW me I
think it will that director he's a good
director
yeah and Jeff Nathanson rush hour 3
screenplay
hello no it's the funny [ __ ] hey amigos
and amigas and animals I'm Greg
Perry PN big t make a P make a P Kevin
you do the line you know your honor
really what just just take your arm and
P oh I see what's it yeah yeah that
works
yeah now we [ __ ] be never off onto
her Instagram Collider videos hey happy
life [ __ ] say could you react to the
new parts of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales international trailer thanks
Perry
let's do it cool little will you yeah
we're the subtitles at Milan good
because she's not playing you know I'm
trying to just do the right thing and
watch the right trailer is this the
right one yeah this is on movieclips
trailers english auto-generated okay
that's not happening retinol model your
token Pat oh boy not English probably
should just find me the english-language
version no this is the international
trailer that he was requesting I think
we've seen the first second like ten
times over now the movie
so uh Nicosia yeah
Kunlun something about Jack Sparrow and
seek revenge
trying to decide with your only hope
okay sure a query on the first back your
pad
yeah no I'm so sorry we still talking
that weirdo you can help King for the
Trident we have to buy this I am done
[Music]
so this out
[Music]
moving up the ladder will keira
knightley what I thought you were in it
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh come on Harry never up even though we
couldn't understand the voiceover that
we cared so much about from the trailer
narrator that looks like a fun every
time I see one of these trailers
Lincoln's all they need to do I mean the
Pirates franchise whether the movie is
good or not they're going to continue to
crush it
and that was like fun that looks like a
slow blood I feel like this is harkening
back more of the first one it will it
they have all three of them they found
Johnny Depp Keira Knightley and Orlando
Bloom and I want to say that I like the
new ones they have - I really want poor
Brenton boys to have a good movie that
poor kid it's like they've been trying
to make him happen for so many years and
he's just not is the new pretty boy yeah
yeah you know girly boy but he's he's
had a string of big-budget misses and
he'll episodes not a miss but he didn't
do anything
yeah well I had no I thought Keira
Knightley wasn't going to be in this one
yeah I know the only reason I do is
because I think that's the English
language one over there and everybody
was writing it out dislike new virus
trailer was here a night Liam what is
not English that's probably being much
fun
[Music]
they told you boom they're all in
Japanese I really yeah the international
trailer be learning Taylor's work this
is international many more countries
overseas no totally and they chose Japan
to reveal keira knightley was and I
really thought oh just a Linda bloom
coming back that makes you really want
to see this
like everyone even all supporting going
through soo much of them the other
trailers in America at least the
domestic ones they didn't show like oh
it's all pirate cruise back here yeah I
don't think I see yeah everyone's coming
this there's like a really fun movie
nothing really compares to the Black
Pearl that movie is so good even when I
put it on so today it holds up so much
so much fun and then you get into all
that nonsense and kind of Johnny Depp
hamming it up yeah too much of what he
had done before but it does look like
more of the same in that respect here
but if they have enough people around
and I feel like it'll be okay yeah and
giant death um interviews I read with
him that by song collider.com well then
of [ __ ] he had to say and [ __ ] Jeff
Nathanson had to say it sounded like
Johnny Depp was a lot more invested in
this one this specific one I think
because he intends for this to be if I
don't believe that [ __ ] attention this
between a rock solid if this if this
winds up you know breaking box-office
records or even just making a ton of
money into that well I don't think it's
going to do that well as a domestic
box-office compared to other summer
blockbusters overseas I think that's why
we're getting Japanese trailer maybe
yeah but it works overseas is we're
going to make a ton of money all over
again well I think the second I know the
second enforcement over a billion
dollars and I think the third one did be
very surprised if it did yeah yeah I
mean even the fourth one didn't even
have Keira Knightley you are low man
little made over a billion so I can only
imagine what they seem like they're
barely going to be in the movie though
oh yeah they seem like they're really
small appearances I have a feeling it's
going to be Johnny Depp in the two
newcomers and they're going to do a
front and center the entire time but
she's great too I forget
Kaya Scodelario probably saying that
wrong no you're not really I know I do
okay I'm just gonna lie you should just
like me I really liked her from Maze
Runner
yeah I can't put my finger on the movie
that needs a little more credit than it
got first runner is absurd just for the
heck of it go to Collider go to Collider
calm and see what their most recent
pirates trailer was all right click the
trailer tab I'm gonna helping you guys
learn how to use Collider which is a
great resource to find the latest
trailers I'm telling you it's going to
come up and it's going to appear
Knightley's name in it and I wonder if
that one's in English where is it there
I swear it's bad I saw it
pirate I'll see you Harris no pirate I
can't type and what's happening here
let's type yeah Jack okay clearly I
finally lost them you have become
delusional
I'm telling you're all Japanese those
lines were there I'm sorry I'm sorry
Perry but hey that movie looks like a
ton of black does a ton of black there
is a lot of blacks in that movie
whatever set me a second three don't say
that I've been in this is a very busy
life this is a children's movie use that
kind of language in a Christian home
like my adult living sorry early
friendly movies it's a high seas
family-friendly adventure that's what it
is
I like that last bit with I don't know I
thought it was so funny when he's about
to be hum exactly humming and he flips
often like it's not what you invented I
don't know I'm going to be some stupid
slapstick comedy where he likes all flat
on his face yeah I called you like just
before you thought it was gonna happen
should have happened it was something
else
and that was probably a little bit swans
only thing I'm now she probably eating a
show up and do it
they probably just like CGI her I don't
know
no I would think she's in a little more
than that I would hope so
I doubt it watch prove me wrong but I
don't I don't know if I can do this
you're wrong because there's a good
there is a chance that that's gonna
happen I'm looking for a little more me
- of course I want more I just don't
think they're gonna do that
Karen IV seems like she's she's better
what's Karen keira knightley up to now
you know being Keira Knightley she don't
in black hat with Chris Hemsworth I Chih
point was she opposite him in it hoping
I would say google it but it's probably
wrong out there
anything I say no longer exists on the
internet there is no Englishman survivor
therapy in anywhere Keira Knightley she
was my crush one of my crushes gone
after the first pirate yang oh man I
fell in love with her III thought like
one day I grow up when I'm an adult she
was already an adult that we would like
somehow find each other and marry each
other but sadly that has not happened
she turned out to be a total [ __ ] knows
her father's her loss she lost yeah yeah
yeah you know I was great to her and she
wanted to be with me she's like Greg the
intercourse we have is amazing that that
was her words make sure I'm gonna go
home for the night and he is gonna be
sitting here his computer and you're
going to be like mountain men and
animating her mouth is so true yeah no I
do that definitely but it didn't work
out because she's just too needy yeah I
mean oh I do I do look at her and think
that she's probably really demanding
yeah very deny it I get it
very mad that's offended unfortunately
you know my god is hotter than her
anyway oh wait I wanted to give a
patreon shoutout
totally jumbled he's a longtime
subscriber of the channel he donated $30
to us yeah anything
$30 meaning you get to be part of the
Google hangout for thing - making a
livestream hangout on patreon and you
get actually be there and talk with us
Oh
we have exclusive live streams on
patreon now it's a pretty cool idea it's
a really cool idea I think I like that
better than the handwritten letter where
you stalk someone idea oh oh oh the
stocking boy the stocking part was the
best part I would stop totally jumbled
you haven't seen this guy but he yeah he
is a fantastic looking gentle man well
and then I would go you know the shows
going
I go gaze I got to stop yeah thanks
totally jumbled and by the way you can
subscribe to the real rejects right now
there should be an end screen appearing
Harry Nemiroff Collider [ __ ] video oh
yeah
youtube.com slash Collider [ __ ] video
different go there P [ __ ] Nemiroff no
no no baller a P memoral oh so
respectful I'm a gentleman
well then P Nemiroff all over there I
kind of want to walk around and say keep
[ __ ] them around I just own that who
are you I'm P [ __ ] Emma off who the
[ __ ] are you